this come this is not a farmer thing at
all
cue imagine hello and welcome back to
America hello welcome back to the
universe's favorite game show Widow Oh
God
universe's favorite game show will it
mm-hmm
sudden my body is trying to stop me from
moving forward and producing this video
can't stop my body even though you
constantly try my game show which I take
3 how cold items and try to see if I can
make a bikini out of this the last
episode I tried to make Keeney's out of
what did I try to make you use our old
jeans a paper bag and old don't do it
this time I took your suggestions and
our contestants for this episode will
Akeem e-r e-r e-r oil
I really have are you okay
like real class Italy rule to the game
show is that I try to make bikinis using
whatever I have in my house and then we
see if it keeps you from seeing my bacon
bit let's begin round one anyone start
with tin foil I think the zucchini but I
think it's going to be painful this will
be sliced well try it again you would
think I would have more game plan and
going into this no way
oh this is gonna hurt my cooter it's not
the official tagline of Willy Keaney yet
we're still work shopping but it's a
pretty good one how do we get just
Keaney I'm just gonna let the foil
speaks to me about how it wants bikini
Oh Keaney time
okay lure them together out metal does
form heat very quickly okay
a dream of mine has always been to feel
like a really sexy human bacon cake okay
so we're hanging a little low if this
YouTube thing doesn't keep panning out
for me
get ready local high schools I'm coming
for your art teaching position or
science
if the Tin Man was the bachelor I want
to look like one of the contestants on
that season okay we have our top sort of
well let that be over here now the
bottom didn't side my bottoms right like
a real modest teeny bada real truck for
my cooter something we're going to let
that sit and move on to our other Keeney
next is the old pillowcase which I think
will probably be that you give zucchini
because it's fabric yeah if you're my
homemade chassis belt
I have ideas for this that this is
already sewn here nice okay money whoa
okay but I think this might fit weird so
I'm going to cut these themes and the
fabric to the sides I could potentially
just tie them up on the side think that
we cheating but there are no winners
here just one loser
I should be self-aware I know doesn't
look like it but the Bikini Bottom made
from a pillowcase it's done a little too
attached we're just going to try
something okay notice this like I'm just
cutting [ __ ] and that's exactly what it
is no I have a plan alright so case is
so wrinkled you guys it's truly the most
embarrassing part of this video
okay we're down like a teeny top but I
worried that's very see-through so I'm
gonna just hot glue on some fabric to
the underside of it to make the tent a
coverage slightly less transparent okay
I think okay okay Jeannie it's done
we'll come back to the side and I'll
start our lap kami shop Jeannie and I've
been making all these genies the thing
sort of silhouettes I'm wondering if
there is a more interesting to me I can
make with these speak to me dirty old
socks that's not a kini at all just
cutting worried about the sock kini guys
we're a little in pretty bad run like a
figure of what I wants to be let's say
we can figure out this top part just
kini feelings of sake Annie might come
around
aki-nee might not talk I had to I'm
sorry I get one I'm done okay I think
all of our key needs have been made to
the best that they're gonna be for this
moment in time in this household
I wanna see Wilma kini kini number one
top half kind of cutie bah ah oh no no
stop half dozen it Keaney it kami well
there you go guys is no episode of well
if Cheney we were basically two to two
and a half for free this time I really
hope you do give us thumbs up and make
some comments about what other items I
should try to Cheney don't hear too
quick subscribe and hit that little bill
so your notifications to that post video
is inconsistently on on Monday Wednesday
Friday basis I don't know I'm just a
girl at home making some cheap Chinese
mac and cheese candy making cheeky girl
with sour cream again Keeney's by
herself not even her dog is actually
here at the moment download on iTunes